guys i think it's official i survived
the texas blackout went 72 hours without
power but
we're back 10 million studios back up
and running what's up
today i just want to talk to you guys a
bit of about what what it was like what
it was like to be
in we're going to tell our kids about
this right like the time that i lost
power you know all jokes aside there
were some serious consequences to this
look i was one of the lucky ones right i
lost power for 72 hours but we did have
water the entire time
i know a lot of people whose pipes burst
so
there's resulting in flooding i know
people who didn't have water or power
people literally died from this honestly
and it was all basically preventable
from what i understand because the
weather conditions were not
unlike what you'd see basically anywhere
else in the world i mean in texas you
know it's obviously an anomaly for it to
be snowing
but everywhere else in the world like
four inches of snow five six inches of
snow
it's like a normal tuesday in the winter
right uh but for us
it was yeah the sky fell basically we
tested the system we said oh
did we prepare knock knock and no one
was home
it was supposed to be the responsibility
of ercot electric reliability council of
texas now
what people didn't understand was that
reliability the r
is actually silent uh so it's just ecot
it's just there is no reliability and
everyone's just pointing fingers because
yeah the
ercot ceo is basically like well it
could have been way worse
i was on one article we almost spun out
into months without power so you guys
should be thanking us
and some people were blaming like oh
it's the renewables at fault like all
the wind turbines froze up
and other people saying well it's the
natural gas lines that froze up
this seems to be like the most middle
ground take and we just fail to
weatherize which is where you like prep
your grid i don't i don't know i don't
really care about that stuff
what i do care about is ted cruz
taking a trip did you guys see this
so in the middle of me freezing everyone
freezing in texas
uh our boy cruise took a vacay
to cancun
packing up packing heavy mr cruz now i
was offended
heavily offended by this number one
where's the invite
i would i could get out the board shorts
you know never heard a word
okay maybe he's too busy taking care of
his daughters whatever his excuse was i
think he blamed on his kids
i i was torn what applies here because i
thought of two
at first i thought of this quote the
captain always goes down with his ship
aka you don't leave texas if you're in
the government of texas freeze
your ass off like a man like the rest of
us okay
but he didn't do that but then i thought
to myself i talked to some other people
they were like what's the big deal i
would have gone too and they're right i
mean i definitely would have gone
but i thought about this saying put your
oxygen own oxygen mask
on first i thought wow we've got a lot
of
contradictory self-help sayings in the
united states
because i was like well this kind of
contradicts that maybe ted cruz wanted
to put on his own oxygen mask
oh my gosh dude i love it i just love
when these politicians get caught in
these blunders
obviously you should not be going on a
vacation and he's like oh i was such a
good dad
he tried to blame it on his kids can you
imagine a more cowardly thing to do
you get caught with your pants down and
you're like oh it's my daughter's
my daughters just had to go on a trip
that's like the whole statement he's
like my
i just wanted to be a good dad my
daughters were cold
and they wanted a place with power and
you know everything else it's like hey
you know who else is called
the entire state the entire state was
called
but yeah i don't know i think you could
probably take both sides on this you
could be like
yeah you can literally just choose your
idiom here
now for us personally how bad did it get
well uh this photo should show you
everything you need to know
uh we were outside boiling water on a
little propane heater that luckily i had
that came in clutch and we're
balancing it on some dumbbells that i
never use and so that's the most use
they've ever gotten which is cool
glad they got to get some finally some
use out of that but all in all it was
like just a
elaborate camping exercise mandated
camping
every citizen in texas got to enjoy a
little
camping some more extreme than others
now one thing i did want to show you
guys is it got desperate for a minute
there for a minute there i went
full panic i think everyone did we were
really wondering we're like when's the
power going to come back on whatever and
we heard
rumors we got a viral hoax that said
that
water was going to turn off uh and we
were freaked out about that
so we wanted to store some water and
actually take it to one of our in-laws
who also lost the water
and so this was a little contraption
that we were getting top here
i had to do a little uh redneck
engineering to collect
water yeah so uh you think your life's
going bad
okay coffee's a lot this is the life of
a
guy with 10 million dollars yeah this is
uh definitely not my
the finest moment in my life but hey
engineer though confirmed engineer
by the way we're having like we had
water problems before this
so pay no mind of that that was just
some construction we had going on in our
kitchen
that's right that has nothing to do with
the fact that the pipes
we just had a disaster actually recently
that that's a whole other issue
come to find out we had a leak
they didn't know it insurance is going
to cover it but anyway our house is like
floors are ripped out
sorry that's a tangent the point is here
is my life size
and you guys think i just lived this
glorious life
of just busting gurus but little do you
know the reality
of coffeezilla this is a day in the life
you're makeshifting a cardboard tube
into
a water pipe to get what collect water
to make sure you don't run out of water
because your state government is
incompetent on my part i guess it is a
wake-up call
that maybe all those preppers were right
you guys have anybody in your life who's
a prepper like this i've got several
okay i feel like the per capita of
preppers in texas is slightly higher
and i have close friends who for years
have been telling me stephen
it's coming and i'm always like
what it's always vague right it's like
the deep state it you know
it's got us we're gonna be in trouble
whatever you gotta buy guns buy
all this stuff buy supplies and i'm
always thinking to myself
nah you're just too much it's too much
now
he tell me you asked me five days ago
you saw this coming this is a low point
in every man's life first of all what's
up with this pink
bucket my wife chose okay i have some
respect
for the man at the house but the point
is
did i see myself doing this no and if i
had been a prepper
i'd have a beautiful black tote to look
like a man
while collecting my water i'd have a
pipe you know a little faucet hose
going over i'd probably already have
bottled water in
other words i wouldn't be caught with my
pants down
uh instead i relied on my government
wait is this sort of the republican
argument
my the government failed me but it was a
republican government so does that mean
we need
more government or alternatively i can
take matters into my own hands and make
sure that i don't rely on government at
all
that's the ultimate conservative
argument i don't know i'm not a
politician and i'm not political
but the point is i just want to tell you
guys what happened in my life last thing
i guess i just wanted to say thank you
for all the well wishes
i uh posted on the community tab a lot
of you guys were nice
some of you guys were saying that i
should shave my head
uh shave your head should have added a
axe of god clause first of all you're
heartless literally
i could have had a stroke but in the
hospital you'd have been like hey
first shave your head
ruthless okay but second of all y'all
didn't pay attention to the fine print
this is how you're getting scammed by
the way all these guys have in their
claws like actually this course is gonna
make you no money but it's at the bottom
right
you guys not reading the fine print
because if you had you would have seen
this
and gentlemen if i miss an upload in
january
of 2021 in january guys it's february
the challenge is over i'm not shaving my
head for nothing
okay forget about it i've got enough
problems
my life's falling apart my kitchen tore
up
because uh it got already having prob
like like leaks in the house didn't know
about then you got the winter blizzard
then i find out my audience is all bots
i mean guys it's tough being me so i
wanted to update you guys
and just explain everything that was
going on and so that's basically it is
there a way to wrap this up uh
oh texas can be great but we're you know
everything's bigger in texas you ever
heard that expression that's just true
across the board for good and bad things
that's the problem
they don't tell you that when you come
in the state you're thinking oh
bigger burgers right
bigger stacks of cash what they don't
tell you
bigger power outages so yeah it just
comes with the territory thought i'd
tell you guys my story
that's it see ya i know what you need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee